aren't you a little bit concerned about
the economic chaos that brexit has
created well let's just get a few things
straight you know sterling is down a bit
but it's been in the bear mug bit well
hang on it's at a 30-year low hang on
it's been in the bear market since July
2014 so we've seen the declining
currency for a long time the footsie
today
was up 3% and indeed 12% up 12% up since
it's February still way down from Friday
now it's 12% up from February so let's
get a sense of perspective on where
these markets are okay now Draghi may
have a point if we don't come to a
grown-up trade deal between the United
Kingdom and the euro zone it will hurt
the euro zone which is why today in
Parliament I was urging a grown-up
approach he also said he's afraid this
is going to lead the competitive
devaluations foreign currency wars what
would you say to that well I would say
this that all my experience you know in
dealing in commodities and currencies
before coming into politics says to me
that the worst systems aren't ones where
currencies go down and go up there ones
where you fix currencies and people and
people find themselves trapped inside an
economic prison because that's what's
happened to Greece it's happened to
Italy it's happened to Spain I would
rather go completely against Draghi I'd
rather see countries able to have
competitive devaluations but get trapped
inside the Euro mark Ernie you said you
would like to see him resign yes why
because he's the governor of the Bank of
England he's supposed to be independent
he played a completely partisan role in
that referendum